c'est d'abord féminin ça existe ça
existe de plus en plus oui on est
différente des hommes en tant que femme
est vraisemblablement en tant que
cinéaste mais il faudrait pas que
socialement ce soit perçu socialement il
faudrait que les gens aillent voir des
films bon bon film mauvais film sa selle
c'est leur goût de le savoir
au fond ils devraient pas savoir
tellement si c'est une femme ou un homme
qu'il a fait et ça ne devrait pas
tellement être jugé comme tel il y avait
récemment il ya deux trois mois il y
avait six films de femmes sur les écrans
parisiens en exclusivité j'ai des bons
c'est quand même un phénomène nouveau et
qui ne va énormément son caissier qui va
s'amplifier ça veut dire qu'il faudra
faire face très très peu dans très peu
de temps un phénomène complètement
naturel il y aura peut-être autant de
femmes cinéastes que d'hommes cinéaste
et que le problème va en même temps se
dissoudre et se préciser c'est à dire on
va commencer à regarder les films en
avant est ce que ces défis qui nous
intéresse qui intéressent les femmes 4s
les ans mes enfants j'ai pas quoi est ce
que ça rapporte de l'argent et toutes
ces questions habituelles du cinéma et
puis en même temps on va voir se précise
et vraisemblablement une nouvelle
culture cinématographique qui se dessine
mais je crois qu'il faut qu'on commence
à refuser fermement d'en parler de faire
nous mêmes les théories les conclusions
les blablas là dessus mais un phénomène
nouveau aussi c'est les femmes qui
s'empare de la technique elle s'en
empare en apprenant genève parce qu'on
sait très bien que bon je vais dire une
chose qui est connu mais jusque là les
équipes de films qu'on voyait quand même
essentiellement comme femme la scripte
et la maquilleuse ou la coiffeuse et il
y avait le côté comme ça il faut bien
qu'ils de petites femmes dans une équipe
et c'est un peu là n'ont pas nié le
sourire le charme et tout ça tu peux me
donner un cachet cocotte bon et peut
plus on voit arriver dans les équipes de
cinéma des femmes des jeunes femmes qui
se sont dit mais le son ça m'intéresse
je peux être un très bon ingénieur du
son il ya des cadres eux il ya des
directrices de photographie il ya des
filles au point
il y a des filles d'allah régis
administration et on s'aperçoit que
métier d'homme ça ne veut rien dire
un métier d'homme ce sera un métier
qu'il va ne peut pas faire il y en a
vraiment peu en fait
donc c'est un métier fait par les hommes
jusqu'à présent qui est en train d'être
fait par les femmes et à mesure que les
femmes se familiarise avec la technique
et la possède naturellement on change
aussi le cinéma
[Musique]